dès la semaine prochaine les yeux du
monde entier seront à nouveau tournés
vers la capitale française puisque
malgré les attentats quarante mille
personnes sont attendues à cette grande
conférence de l'onu sur les changements
climatiques qui débute officiellement
lundi le 30 novembre
catherine bonsoir censé lui il ya
plusieurs qui voit cette conférence
comme un moment vraiment charnière est
vraiment copenhague ils vont construire
de cet échec
mais on n'a pas droit à l'échec
effectivement il l'objectif est
ambitieux céline se doter du tout
premier accord universel sur le climat
et le mot universel est important parce
que rappelons-nous le protocole de kyoto
ne concernait que quelques pays
industrialisés il expire en 2020 et
malgré qu'ils aient tout on a vu les
émissions de gaz à effet serre monter en
flèche
d'ailleurs en 2015 on voit franchir fort
probablement la barre du 1 degrés de
réchauffement
quand on sait que deux degrés c'est le
seuil critique à ne pas franchir
donc là on a demandé à tous les pays de
faire leur part il ya plus de 160 pays
qui ont fourni leurs contributions
nationales pour réduire le réchauffement
climatique al'approche de don de cette
conférence à paris et ça ça représente
environ 90 pour cent de toutes les
émissions de la banque
on a changé la méthode en fait on a dit
à travailler en amont que seraient plus
facilement les encore loin d'une entente
oui bon le financement est un autre
point bien sûr litigieux il ya les pays
il ya une responsabilité des pays riches
qui ont pollué qui polluent et les pays
émergents les pays pauvres qui disent
pourquoi est ce que ce serait nous qui
paierons et ce sont eux qui paient le
prix en fête du oui on s'est longuement
climatique oui ce sont eux qui sont les
plus impactées
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'en 2009 à
copenhague on s'est quand même entendu
les pays riches se sont engagés à
mobiliser 100 milliards de dollars par
année jusqu'à 2020 pour aider les pays
les plus pauvres à faire face aux effets
des changements climatiques donc cette
année on a déjà amassé la plaine près de
80 milliards de dollars
par contre en 2009 on avait jamais
précisé est ce que c'est de l'argent
public ou privé est ce que ce sont des
dons ou des prêts ce sont quand même des
questions fondamentales
il n'y a toujours pas de réponse donc ça
sera au centre des négociations à paris
bon les joueurs importants les états
unis la chine
oui certainement etats unis chine les
deux plus grands pollueurs de la planète
si on veut un accord plusieurs experts
disent il y aura un accord à paris on
sent qu'ils sont ils sont très
volontaires ils ont ils font preuve de
beaucoup d'ouverture on n'avait jamais
vu ça
par contre il faudra surveiller un autre
joueur clé l'inde troisième plus gros
pollueurs de la planète
l'inde qui compte toujours 2 140
millions de personnes qui n'ont pas
accès à l'électricité et donc lundi nous
la priorité c'est le développement
faudra donc convaincre le géant mais
c'est là d'ailleurs qui parle de justice
climatique
oui alors on se revoit à paris merci
beaucoup catherine ça m'a fait plaisir